Wright announced the results of their
ever Noble quest of defeating Smurfs so
what will your encounter smurfs look
like player role initiative
[Music]
guys before we get into the video just a
reminder to check out our new merch
releases we have a cool cream hoodie I
know we talked about it last time but I
seriously love it it's absolutely Gorge
so check it out the link in the
description below what is the one thing
we all hate in valorent no not the one
in 10 jet on your team I'm talking about
Smurfs Smurf accounts are in their most
basic form accounts used by players that
are a lot more skilled than that
account's rank so in valorant a diamond
player might have a silver account for a
variety of reasons that silver account
is that player Smurf smurfs have been a
constant complaint in multiplayer
matchmaking games and valorent is no
exception most players have dealt with
Smurfs When They smash you it sucks when
they carry you it can feel pretty good
but either way everyone can admit that
Smurfs go against the whole point of
having a skill based matchmaking system
despite this a quick YouTube search will
show you that it's also a super popular
content creation theme and a quick
search on Fiverr shows that people will
make an account a Smurf for you at a
reasonable price smurfs have a
significant place in the balance
community and the devs know this too a
year ago they said that Smurfs are their
most requested topic to talk about as a
part of their valorant system Health
series and finally almost exactly a year
later we have an in-depth article about
Smurf detection and prevention so a
buckle up Babes it's about to get mathy
the first thing they cover is automated
Smurf detection back in patch 5.01 they
implemented a new part of their
detection system in North America that
was quote designed to make sure that new
players that means all new accounts are
matched up with players of the correct
skill level much faster than before in
basic terms that means recognizing a new
account someone had made as a Smurf and
pushing it out of the incorrect ELO so
how is it automatically detected their
first test was with Stomps Riot defines
Stomps as a team winning by eight or
more rounds argue about that in the
comment section I do not have time to
deal with that they claimed that there
was a Smurf stomp rate of 32 percent
that means basically that Smurfs were
stomping one out of every three games
they said that they wanted to bring down
the 32 percent to be within one percent
of the non-smurf stomp range they later
said that the non-smurf stomp range is
18 in unrated games to test this
automated system they identified Smurfs
took half of them and adjusted their MMR
through the new system the other half
was left alone as a control group for
comparison as you can see with this
graph the smurs who had their Mr
adjusted within the new system did fall
within one percent of the target stomp
rate while non-adjusted Smurfs were
stomping 25 of the time this was tested
in Na and when they tested globally they
say they saw similar results and then no
more tests the new detection system was
determined a success and they launched
the new system globally in September
another big change discussed in this
article was to five Stacks Rye
identified that one of the main reasons
people make Smurf accounts is to play
with their lower ranked friends but they
can't because of rank restrictions in
patch 3.10 they made a change where any
players of any rank could 5 stack
together this crash shows when they
dropped that change people did take
advantage of it but this graph
highlights those who were only able to
five stack after the changes AKA their
ranks were too far apart before although
there wasn't a massive jump in the
number of five sacks an increasing
amount of five sex are made of groups
that wouldn't have been able to stack
before the changes more five sacks made
of players with wide rank distributions
may be great for dealing with Smurfs but
then you have to remember fairness you
see some of you may be thinking to
yourself right now well I'm iron I'll
just get four reading friends to carry
me jump up a million ranks and maybe
ruin a kid's day along the way nice try
but Riot are one step ahead of you your
RR wouldn't actually change that much
because of the RR reduction setup for
rank disparity back in patch 3.10 and
according to Riot the data shows us that
the match fairness did not meaningfully
shift downward as a result of the five
stock changes in fact five stack matches
became more close after we made these
changes since players were playing less
than their Smurfs and More in their
Mains it was easy for our matchmaking to
ensure a fair match today over a third
of all five stack matches end in a 13 to
10 or closer five stack matches are
actually closer in score than any other
match in competitive and that's it they
end the article by saying that this
pretty much worked because they saw an
overall reduction in secondary accounts
but they will continue to work on it
personally in my opinion this is a great
way to start but people who want to play
with their friends on Smurf accounts
aren't going to be trying that hard
anyways the annoying Smurfs this might
work what are you guys think do you guys
think this solves a problem this is
unintentionally creating more problems
let me know down in the comment section
below and if you're worried about your
Smurf account right now all I gotta say
is good luck
okay so hi everyone it's Liz welcome to
Liz's dice bath it's very heavy and it's
really good to travel with if you ever
need to travel and play D D because you
can like open it up and it'll stay open
like this you have a spot for all your
dice like my d20s are all here but oh
this is oh this is my first D20
I just got really excited